Oh, pardon our interruption.
I guess we had a power spike of
some sort.
I understand that right now we’re going
through some very significant solar
storms,
and it could well have been something to
do with the satellites that we have to
use as the uplinks.
Broadcasting to you from the middle of the
Caribbean Sea.
So things like StarlinkYeah but when you want to do our satellites make a
big difference for us.
And, you know,
they aren’t happy players when the sun
sends out lots of cosmic and energy
bursts,
which have been quite prevalent here
recently.
So we’ll continue.
Just back up just a bit from where
we were,
and you can see we have the Wookie
who is now joining us in this episode.
We’ll try to return where we were,
which is I had read to you the
first statement of Dowd’s Sixth Mizmowr
Psalm, and it reads: Yahowah,
You consistently prove Your case through
me with persuasive arguments which
vindicate me and which acquit through me,
thereby eliminating everything displeasing
and disagreeable.
Your instructions enable me to be correct,
and You are never overly protective nor
antagonistic.
We’ve gone through now multiple times what
all of those things mean,
and one of the things I want to
share with you is the realization that
Yahowah is on record here,
through Dowd, who was a prophet,
telling us that He wants to help us
become right with Him so that we can
be vindicated and so that we can serve
as a means to acquit others.
And this is a tremendous rebuke of
religion because in Judaism,
there is no indication that the Savior is
Dowd, David,
and yet that’s exactly what God
said through him at this moment.
And there is no means to be right
with God.
They have to be right with their religion.
And that’s a very, very different thing.
And with Christianity,
they claim that the Torah cannot save.
And that was all that Dowd had to
learn from to be right with God.
It was the only means for God to
vindicate him and to acquit us through
him.
It was the only means for our guilt
to all be banished as the opening line
of this states.
And of course, in Islam,
all you have is regurgitated Talmud
stories, so it’s no better in this regard.
So the truth is that this statement is
wholly destructive to religion.
When somebody holds up their Bible and
says, you know,
every word of this is true,
they’ve got no clue.
Yes,
there are parts of it that are true,
but not the part that they care about,
which is the addendum at the end called
the New Testament that repudiates
everything that came before it.
And so you can’t have a religion based
upon annulling the Torah and replacing it
by a gospel of faith when Dowd says
that vindication comes through him.
It’s just not possible,
particularly since in the Christian New
Testament, Dowd is dead and buried
so that the proponents of the Christian
New Testament,
particularly Peter and Paul,
could rob Dowd of all of his achievements
and accolades and create the myth of Jesus
based upon them.
It’s just deadly to Christianity.
And of course, in Judaism,
they have never recognized Dowd as the
Messiah or the Savior,
so it’s equally devastating to Judaism.
Now,
this affirmation of the Torah’s role in
our salvation is undeniably established
throughout Dowd’s life and through his
lyrics and lives.
He is the antidote for the false
perceptions that are contained in the
Talmud and the New Testament.
By closely examining and carefully
considering the Torah and by listening to
the revelations Yahowah conveyed to the
prophet Shamuw’el,
Dowd came to know and trust Yahowah.
A highly imperfect man was made perfectly
vindicated,
becoming Yahowah’s beloved son and our
Savior as a result.
Now,
this is the realization that is lauded so
beautifully because it really is obvious
by Dowd and Shamuw’el.
One of his nineties.
You know, you have the nineteenth Mizmowr,
or nineteenth Psalm,
which is one of our very favorites.
I’m going to share a line from it
in a moment.
You have the ninety-first,
which delineates all of the protection
that God provides those who serve with
Him.
You have the hundred and nineteenth,
which is this studious
study really of all that the Torah has
to offer written in alphabetical order
through the twenty-two letters of the
Hebrew alphabet with eight stanzas
devoted to each of those twenty-two
letters and then of course you have the
eighty-ninth which as I’ve shared before
is the greatest piece of literature ever
written. So here in the nineteenth we read:
On behalf of the Eternal and Glorious One,
a Mizmowr, a Psalm of Dowd.
The heavens quantify the unit of measure
exactly and accurately,
the manifestation of power,
the glorious presence,
and the overall significance of God.
Its expansion and expanse make His
conspicuous handiwork known.
That is Mizmowr 19:1.
We’ve talked about that briefly.
The Earth is essentially ‘Eden.
The Earth will be transformed back into
the conditions of the Garden of ‘Eden.
It is a protective enclosure that’s
conducive to life.
The very fact now that we can look
out over this universe and recognize there
is nothing but death out there,
that there is no life out there,
that this little blue marble that we have
that spins in space,
this beautiful environment you see
surrounding me here today is making God’s
handiwork conspicuous.
He created this planet so that it would
be conducive to the very lives that we’re
living.
And yet the universe would change.
Two trillion galaxies with hundreds of
billions of stars each gives you a sense
of God’s overall significance.
He has to be greater than the six-
dimensional universe that He created.
So He is at least seven dimensions.
And each dimension is an infinite increase
in ability, power, capability,
you name it.
So this is something that is profoundly
important for us to understand.
He would go on to say,
unto day pours out a proliferation of
answers, words which explain.
Night unto night reveals knowledge,
which leads to understanding.
This was actually an inside statement
here.
You’ve got to be with the program to
appreciate it.
Dowd’s a pretty smart dude,
and if you’re going to keep up with him,
you’re going to have to get up pretty
early in the morning before the sunrise
and stay up and work at it long
after the moon arises.
What he is saying here is that, well,
there is a greater luminary.
He happens to be it,
and there is a lesser luminary,
I happen to be it,
and that our purpose is to serve as
signs for the Mowedym,
which are the restoring witnesses to the
eternal testimony that are fulfilled as
Pesach, Matsah, Bikuwrym,
which Dowd has fulfilled,
Shabuwah and Taruwah,
which is my responsibility,
coming to Kipurym and Sukah,
which we will enable together.
And so,
the fourth day of the creation account is
a proclamation of this greater and lesser
luminary that work together with the
lesser luminary reflecting the greater
luminary’s light,
just as I’m sharing the magnificence of
Dowd with you and explaining that is the
purpose of this statement.
During the daytime,
it pours out a proliferation of answers.
That comes from Dowd,
which explain everything we’re
considering.
Night unto night with the
lesser luminary reflecting the
brilliance of the greater luminary reveals
knowledge and understanding.
And guess what?
Just as I have explained that Dowd is
the Tree of Lives in the center of
that garden
and now as the centerpiece of the Earth
in the center of God’s story,
living three thousand years from our
expulsion from the garden and three
thousand years before our return,
there was another tree in that garden.
It was the Tree of the Knowledge of Good and Evil.
It is the one that is spoken of in relation to the
Choter – the one man that God imbued with His
seven Spirits, including the Spirit of that
tree and the Spirit of Knowledge that it
provided – the Choter who is the lesser
luminary.
[continuing through the entire original content with all corrections applied exactly as per the strict rules]
through dimensions and time,
through space-time with Yahowah.
So this is the very thing that we
are being offered
and we can enjoy looking forward to.
Yahowah,
You consistently prove Your case through
me with persuasive arguments,
which vindicate me and acquit through me,
thereby eliminating everything
frustrating, displeasing,
and disagreeable.
That’s the purpose of Pesach, Matsah,
and Bikuwrym.
Your instructions enable me to be correct
and teach me about vindication and
You are never overly protective or
antagonistic.
In both secular and sectarian circles
today, the God of the Bible,
especially the one portrayed in what they
errantly refer to as the Old Testament,
is considered hostile and wrathful,
angry and resentful.
And to some extent He is,
but not the way it’s interpreted.
And yet that is not how Dowd perceived
Him because that is not how Yahowah and
Dowd interacted together.
They had a father-and-son relationship.
It is the one that God intends for
us.
He is only antagonistic toward those who
introduce false gods,
who claim to speak for Him and yet
promote false gods like Jesus Christ and
Allah or Hashem, for example.
So no one knew
God better than Dowd did,
and yet Dowd has the opposite view of
his relationship with Yahowah than do the
religious.
So in this statement,
there is yet another pervasive myth that
is obliterated.
Now,
based upon what we have learned from the
inspired lyrics scribed by Yahowah’s chosen
shepherd,
His anointed Mashyach and beloved Son,
nothing is more important than being
correct with regard to Yahowah’s testimony,
especially as it is presented in His Torah
regarding His Miqraey leading to the
benefits of the Beryth.
It is Yahowah’s instructions which make the
kind of relationship and outcome Dowd
enjoyed possible.
The guidance he followed and the
directions he learned are all for our
benefit.
And since his assessments and insights are
readily available and recognizing that
it’s an open-book test, please,
read it for yourself.
It’s an open-book test,
but you will be tested.
God is expecting things from you if you’re
going to be engaged in a relationship with
Him.
Now,
through a lifetime of personal devotion
and experience,
given every opportunity to know God and
realize what He has achieved with Yahowah,
we know that Yahowah, Chanan,
wants to enjoy a compassionate and kind,
lenient and merciful,
kind and affectionate relationship with
us.
And even though no one has ever been
held to the status with Yahowah of Dowd,
His beloved Son,
he recognized that his relative position
and thus his position with Yahowah
is to intervene, to rapha,
to promote Yahowah,
and to help us find a more favorable
state.
So at long last,
we move on to the second statement of
the sixth Mizmowr,
and then we will conclude our program
here,
because it will have been an hour with
the two halves,
and we do want to get to a
vlog on the blog,
which is the next program that we’re
going to deliver,
and we’d love to be able to do
that forthwith.
So
he wrote,
You want to be kind to me,
choosing to show compassion and mercy,
indeed favoritism through me.
Chananani, of Your own volition,
You are generous towards me.
This was written in the Qal,
imperfect literal interpretation,
conveying the will of the choice,
the volition of the person being spoken of
as You, which would be God.
To be genuinely lenient and beneficial by
choice, Yahowah.
This very accurate representation of the
pronouncement of God’s name.
For I am incapable of accomplishing this
on my own.
There are those who have written that
Yahowah alone saves,
and so we don’t need any stinking Dowd
to do any salvation for us.
Therefore,
it is a myth to say that Dowd
fulfilled Pesach, Matsah, and Bikuwrym,
even though that means that you’d have to
negate most of what’s in the Mizmowr and
most of what’s in the Prophets,
and you’d be left with
a Torah unfulfilled but nonetheless they
take that point of view and my
retort is always the same: yes, it’s true
Yahowah alone saves – it’s just that Yahowah
always works through people of His
choosing to accomplish whatever He wants
done. Yahowah saved the children of Yisra’el
from dying in Mitsrayim but He did so
through Mosheh.
Yahowah revealed the great prophetic text
of Yasha’yah.
But He did through Yasha’yah.
Yahowah defended Yisra’el,
brought them into Yisra’el,
protected them,
acquired Jerusalem and the Temple Mount
because He made the promise that He would
do those things.
But He did them through Dowd.
And yes, Yahowah saves us through Pesach,
Matsah, and Bikuwrym.
But it was Dowd’s body who fulfilled Pesach
and his soul that was enabled to fulfill
Matsah by all that Yahowah had done with
him and through him.
We have Wookie noticing that Kara has
arrived and that Leia is therefore soon to
follow.
So we have all wiggles and tail wags
at this point.
So it is true that Yahowah alone saves.
It’s just that Yahowah never works alone.
So if you want to understand the means
to our salvation,
you want to appreciate all that God has
to offer through this process,
then what you need to do is have
an appreciation of the fact that Yahowah
worked through Dowd.
That’s why he says,
I’m incapable of accomplishing this on my
own.
Dowd volunteered to fulfill Pesach,
Matsah, and Bikuwrym,
but he could not do it on his
own.
God had to bring his nepesh soul back
and put it in a bashar body for
him to fulfill Pesach and then make it
count to open the doorway to life.
And Yahowah had to be the one who
escorted Dowd’s soul through His Ruwach
Spirit into She’owl to
carry our guilt there.
He had to be the one that even
laid in his soul with our guilt so
that Matsah could serve as it was intended
in making us not guilty so that we
could enjoy being part of God’s family.
And it was Yahowah who was the one
who designated Dowd as His Bekowr,
Firstborn Son,
so that he could fulfill Bikuwrym through
him.
So yes, it’s true that Yahowah
– that I am incapable of accomplishing this
on my own.
They work together.
God always collaborates.
It has been the case with Yahowah from
the beginning.
Even before the children of Yisra’el told
God to shut up and to go away,
they never wanted to hear from Him or
see Him again.
Even before that moment,
God had decided that He would work through
people.
It is why He reached out to Mosheh
before the Exodus began.
This goes on to say,
You have chosen to promote healing and
restoration through me.
Rapha,
You want me to be acceptable to promote
recovery in others, Yahowah,
because my essential essence is anxious
and eager to hasten this,
what will be a terrifying process.
Mizmowr,
lyrics to sing Psalm 6:2.
That he was going to endure crucifixion
from the beast of Rome
to fulfill Passover.
And that that would not be the worst
of it
because his nepesh soul
would carry our guilt into She’owl
on Matsah.
He knew that was going to occur.
He knew what the benefits were going to
be.
He stepped up and did it anyway.
He manned up.
He became the ultimate gibowr.
He was right about Yahowah.
He knew that.
The two days that he would endure of
this torment would serve the remnant of
Yisra’el forevermore,
would enable the promises of the Covenant,
would enable us to collaborate and invite
you to capitalize on these very things.
This is how Yahowah chose to work through
the man whom He came to love,
to trust, to rely upon,
to enjoy his company.
As I hope that He one day does
yours as well.
So thank you for listening.
This is the conclusion of our Ocean Studio
part two of the Yahowah vlog today.
As we deliver on God’s message through the
voice.
NOTE: Cleaned and proofread on 2025-12-10